hello there I'm John Oliver host of last
week tonight we're off this week in
honor of July the fourth the annual
American tradition of reminding the sky
who runs so what one we're on Laura
please enjoy this web-only bonus episode
which is gonna be a little different
because as you probably know usually we
pick a main topic each week and explore
it at length arguably in greater detail
than anyone needs objectively for a
longer period than anyone wants tonight
however instead of taking 15 minutes to
do a deep dive into one topic we'll be
taking one minute to do incredibly
shallow dives into 15 different topics
um so let let's start now flip flops
clearly they are just lingerie for foot
fetishists done moving on to ostriches
scary horse birds I don't like them get
away next um the food chain only safe if
you're at the very top moving on orgies
also only safe if you're at the very top
ah next Dan Jones go just guitars whose
parents are cousins give me another
bagels Donuts that gave up on their
dreams this is easy ah one more
subtitles no thank you subtitles stopped
trying to turn my movie into a book uh
dogs amazing dogs are amazing they're
the only friends who will still love you
if you cut off their balls uh moving on
are conspiracy theories they're just
fairy tales grown-ups tell each other on
YouTube um oh here's a good one
Al Roker and Lenny Kravitz cousins
they're cousins
okay seriously there cuz google it
moving on sloppy joes they're just drunk
hamburgers um seagulls like if your
deadbeat brother was a flock of birds
the trans-pacific partnership to complex
no time at this point um butterflies
they're nothing but pretentious
high-maintenance moths and finally
chicken soup I don't care if it's good
for my soul it's salty bird water I'm
not gonna drink it done done so those
are our shallow dives for this week I
know it's not the full last week tonight
experience so to make this a little more
authentically like the usual show I'd
like to show you this picture of a pug
dressed like a slightly larger pug see
it seems that something we do that's all
for now we'll be back with a new episode
of last week tonight on July the 12th
thank you so much for watching and good
night